[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello, I'm Randy Haberkamp.
I'm the Senior Vice
President of Preservation
and Foundation Programs for the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts
and Sciences, and this
is Hollywood Home Movies:
The Virtual Edition!
Some of you may have been to
our Hollywood Home Movies events
at the Linwood Dunn
Theater, or seen us
at various film festivals
or other presentations.
That's great.
Others of you are going, this
is the Academy - what are they
doing with these home movies?
Uncle Joe used to show those.
I don't want to
see those anymore.
They're boring.
Trust me.
This is going to be
a really fun show,
and not only will you see some
home movies of Hollywood stars
and Hollywood behind the
scenes, directors and producers,
but you'll also, I think,
get a different appreciation
for home movies,
because there are
some really wonderful things
that happen in home movies that
aren't around anywhere else.
And I'd like to
introduce you now
to the person who's
curated this show, as well
as all of the home movie
programs that we've done.
Please welcome Lynne Kirste.
Lynne, good to see you.
Thanks for putting
this together for us.
Hey, Randy.
Great to see you,
and hi, everybody.
I love curating the home movie
collection at the Academy,
and I'm thrilled that
we have this opportunity
to share some of these
wonderful films with you.
I think of home movies as being
kind of like a time machine,
because they allow us to
experience the past in a really
personal, intimate way that
no other kind of film does.
While these are
Hollywood Home Movies,
the Academy has
collected thousands
of reels that were shot
by all sorts of people who
use their amateur cameras to
document their lives, families,
and experiences,
and in home movies
we can often see content
and points of view
that are frequently left
out in mainstream film.
The Academy does take home
movies very seriously.
We think they're
important and we
think they're an important part
of our motion picture heritage.
This program will
give us a glimpse,
as Randy said, into
some Hollywood folks
at work and at play from
the 1930s into the 1960s,
and as you may know, Hollywood
was not a very inclusive place
during those years.
But while it's gotten better,
there's still a long way to go.
But even back then,
there were some people
who overcame barriers against
women, people of color,
and other groups to work
in a variety of positions
in Hollywood and beyond.
So this program will feature and
celebrate some of those people,
And I think that they
still inspire us today.
All the home movies in
the program are silent,
so Randy and I will
provide commentary,
and we have a couple of
special guests coming up
who will join us
a little later on.
And right now we have one
other important collaborator
who Randy will introduce.
So home movies were
traditionally done with just
a projector and a screen, but
we wanted to add a little bit
of a professional flair, so
we're going to do like they did
in the silent days before sound
came in - in the early '20s.
We're going to have live
musical accompaniment,
so please welcome our special
guest, the twinkling ivories
of Michael Mortilla.
Hey, kids, nice
of you to drop by.
Thanks for joining us, Michael.
I think the stage is set.
We've got the movies loaded up.
Michael, take it away.
So here we go.
We're going to start out with
some footage from the Florenz
Ziegfeld-Billie
Burke collection.
This is Catalina Island in
1934, and folks from Hollywood
loved to sail over to Catalina
and spend the weekend anchored,
hanging out in their boats.
Here come a couple now.
This is lesbian director
Dorothy Arzner on the right
and actress Billie
Burke on the left.
Arzner was the only woman
directing films in Hollywood
at this point in time.
She had directed her
first film in 1927
and was the only woman director
in Hollywood for many years.
She and Burke were
quite good friends,
and this is Burke's
daughter, Patricia Ziegfeld,
in the beret, and
her friend Blackie.
Sadly, her father,
Florenz Ziegfeld
had died a few years earlier.
Here's Arzner with her
Kodak Jiffy still camera.
She started working in
the film industry in 1919
as an editor and a writer, and
then later became a director,
and was the first woman to be a
member of the Directors Guild.
Here's Blackie again, probably
filmed by Patricia or Billie
Burke.
The two of them
were the ones who
shot this home movie and
many other home movies that
are in their collection.
And that's Blackie's
husband with one
of the great white
steamers behind him.
These were the ferry boats that
took people from the mainland
over to Catalina
Island and back.
So Hollywood folks loved to
come over and sail around.
Sometimes they'd paddle
over to visit people
on each other's
boats, like these two
women seem to have just done, or
they'd go fishing or swimming.
Here goes Patricia diving in.
We'll see her mother in
the water a little later.
I love that nose guard.
Billie Burke is probably
best known today
for playing Glinda the Good
Witch in The Wizard of Oz,
and she made dozens and
dozens of other movies.
Now this is another
day and we're
heading out of
Los Angeles harbor
to visit the Hussar, which
is this enormous yacht.
It was the largest privately
owned yacht in the world
at this time, four
masts, and coming up I
want you to look really
quickly at the right hand
side of your screen for
costume director Adrian.
He's going to show
up for just a second.
There he is, and here
again Arzner and Burke.
And that was Sam Goldwyn with
them, and the four of them
are all going over
to visit the Hussar.
Adrian had designed costumes
for two of Arzner's films,
and he worked on
a number of films
that Burke appeared in,
including Dinner at Eight
and The Wizard of Oz, of course.
So you may be
thinking whoever owns
this yacht must
be pretty wealthy,
and you would be right.
It's E.F. Hutton and
Marjorie Merriweather Post.
Post actually designed the
interiors of the yacht herself.
And it just keeps going.
And now we're back over at
Catalina in Avalon Harbor.
This is Patricia's
boyfriend, and there's Burke
in the water taking a dip.
Billie Burke actually
started off as a stage actor,
and she was very celebrated
in the early 1900s,
and then she had a whole second
career as a popular character
actress in Hollywood.
Dorothy Arzner directed
films into the early '40s
and then during World War II
she directed training films
for the Women's Army Corps.
And later on she joined
the faculty at UCLA
and taught filmmaking there.
We are indebted to our friends
at the UCLA Film and Television
Archive for restoring many
of Arzner's feature films.
And that's our little look
at Billie Burke and Dorothy
Arzner.
It's really great
footage to see, Lynne.
I love seeing Catalina, but
I think, if I'm not mistaken,
we've got some color
footage coming up, as well,
so that's even more exciting.
Yes, we do.
The next home movie
is Catalina in 1935,
shot in early Kodachrome
by actor Gilbert Roland,
and this film has some
footage of William Haines
who was a very popular actor in
the late '20s and early '30s,
but who had just recently been
blackballed by the Hollywood
studios.
So 1935 was a turning
point in his career.
This is when he launched his
second career as a designer
and decorator to the stars.
And what happened
with William Haines
is that he was openly gay and
was in a longtime relationship,
and MGM in 1933
decided that he had
to enter into a phony
heterosexual marriage for PR
purposes.
Well, Haines refused to
do it, and that was it.
He was blackballed
and he was never
able to get another
acting job, so he
turned to designing
and decorating
and had a very successful
second career at it.
So let's have a look
at this home movie.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So here we go with
actor Gilbert Roland.
That's George Cukor in the
white shirt, David O. Selznick,
and Billy Haines is standing
up in the striped shirt.
George Cukor was a good
friend of Haines' and he
was known for throwing
a lot of really
big, gay parties in
Hollywood, and he actually
had Haines to
redecorate his house.
That was one of Haines's
first commissions,
and he turned it into a real
showplace for Cukor's parties.
Selznick loved also
to throw parties
and he's our host for
this yachting party.
So William Haines was in
this longtime relationship
and it turned out to be
a lifetime partnership
with his partner, Jimmy Shields,
and they worked together
over the years when they
started the design business,
and became very successful.
In fact, he's much better
known today as a designer
than he was as an actor.
Here's Gilbert Roland.
He's handed the camera to
someone else for just a moment,
so he can get in the picture.
He's usually behind the
camera in his home movies.
He's so shy.
This is Irene Mayer Selznick
who is married to David
and later became a noted
theatrical producer,
and here we have a couple
of Academy Award winners.
That's screenwriter Herman
Mankiewicz on the left,
and director Lewis
Milestone on the right.
Mankiewicz co-wrote Citizen
Kane and many other classics.
There he goes, Tarzan
diving into the water.
That's Johnny Weissmuller.
As we saw in the
previous home movie,
people would go visit
each other on their yachts
and their boats, and they
usually would actually
come over in a boat,
but Weissmuller just
paddles over on his longboard.
And here's Constance Bennett
on the left waving to us.
She was very popular
in the early '30s
and was constantly on the
cover of movie magazines.
She and Gilbert Roland were
married about a few years
after this film was shot.
They were already a romantic
couple at this time,
and they had two
daughters together.
Gilbert Roland
was born in Mexico
and he grew up in
El Paso, Texas.
Actually, his given name
was Luis Antonio de Alonso,
but he changed it to his
screen name, Gilbert Roland,
based on two of his favorite
actors, John Gilbert and Ruth
Roland.
And he came to
Hollywood as a teenager
and started acting
in silent films,
and worked all the
way up till 1982.
There go Cukor and Haines again.
Haines also decorated
Constance Bennett's house
and also redid her sister
Joan Bennett's house,
as well as many other
Hollywood folks.
Bennett, as well as
being an actress,
had her own line
of beauty products.
Now Gilbert Roland
originally intended
to be a matador like his
father and grandfather,
but then he fell in love with
movies, came to Hollywood
and first worked as an extra,
and then became a fine actor
and also shot some
great home movies.
So our next home movie is
also from Gilbert Roland's
collection, and this one,
he's behind the camera.
That's Dolores Del Rio on the
right talking to Irene Mayer
Selznick.
Del Rio had come to Hollywood
from her native Mexico in 1925
and quickly became
very successful.
King Vidor with
the tennis racket,
perhaps best known for directing
The Big Parade or Hallelujah.
And this is Elizabeth Allen.
She had recently acted in
films like David Copperfield
and A Tale of Two Cities.
There are so many great
clothes in home movies.
That's another thing about
them that's really wonderful.
Now here's a great picture
of John Gilbert, who was also
a great actor and, of
course, one of the people
that Gilbert Roland
took his name from.
And this footage is
kind of bittersweet
because John Gilbert passed
away about six months
after this home movie was shot.
This may be the last moving
image footage of him.
There's David O.
Selznick with King Vidor
and our hostess, Del
Rio, in the background.
The three of them had all worked
on the film Bird of Paradise
a few years earlier.
John Gilbert again and
now dressed in white.
Del Rio had introduced Gilbert
to her good friend Marlene
Dietrich, and Gilbert and
Dietrich were now a couple.
So Del Rio was obviously one
of the most beautiful actresses
in Hollywood, and she was
a huge star at this time,
but she eventually got tired of
the kind of glamor girl parts
that she was offered
in Hollywood.
And she really wanted to
stretch herself as an actress,
so she went back to Mexico
where she had a range of roles
and became a really important
figure in the establishment
of the Mexican film industry.
Here's Gary Cooper
in his mohair suit.
He and Dietrich will soon start
working on the film Desire.
And here's our host, Cedric
Gibbons, MGM art director.
He had a really amazing career.
He was nominated for 39
Oscars and he won 11 times.
And in addition
to winning Oscars,
he is the person who
designed the Oscar statuette.
Gibbons loved to play
tennis, and he and Del Rio
hosted parties like this
one almost every weekend
at their home.
Their house was in Santa Monica,
and in fact it's still there.
It's considered a Los
Angeles historic landmark.
As we look at a little
buffet that's spread out
for the guests...
The woman in the
braids is Rocky Cooper
who is married to Gary Cooper
and was Cedric Gibbons's niece.
And I don't know what
King Vidor is trying
to tell us about his teeth.
You can see a little bit of
the house in the background.
The style is Streamline Moderne,
and Gibbons helped design
the interiors for the house.
Marlene Dietrich who is
good friends with both Del
Rio and Gibbons.
And we get one last look at
our hostess, a screen legend
both in Hollywood and in
Mexico, Dolores Del Rio.
And now we're headed
up to the Bay Area
with cinematographer
James Wong Howe.
Here he is.
Howe's traveling with
his partner Sanora Babb
and several of their friends,
Babb's sister Dorothy,
the novelist James Hilton
and his wife Alice,
and Hungarian photographer
and actor Charles Korvin.
And I love this shot.
It's very interesting
to see what
a professional cinematographer
will do with a home movie
camera.
Look at that, the Golden
Gate Bridge peeking out
of a cloud or perhaps fog.
The bridge had just
opened a few months
before this home movie
was shot in May of 1937.
Here come our
traveling companions.
This is Sanora Babb
in the fur collar.
James Hilton is the tall
man in the long coat,
and that's Alice
in the red scarf
and Dorothy Babb in the
longer scarf on the far left.
And I love this, because here's
James Wong Howe getting out
his light meter to
set up a home movie.
You don't see that very often.
Some beautiful shots
of San Francisco
back in the early days.
The skyline looks
quite different now.
And now we're heading out over
the Oakland Bay Bridge which
had just opened a year before
in 1936 and was at this time
the longest bridge in the world.
We're on the top level
which was for cars.
There was also at that time
a bottom level for trains,
which was later removed.
And you can see the angle
where Howe is looking down
at the people in the
front seat, so you
can tell he's standing
up in the back seat
to shoot this home movie.
That's not very common.
That's another thing that,
as a cinematographer,
he thought of that.
But who else had really
come up with that idea?
He was an extraordinarily
successful cinematographer
and he's considered really
one of the most important
cinematographers in
Hollywood history.
As we look out at
Coit Tower there.
He started in silent films
and he worked all the way up
into the mid '70s.
He was nominated for
10 Academy Awards
and he won twice for The
Rose Tattoo and for Hud.
He and Sanora Babb were a
couple from the '30s onward,
but they weren't allowed
to get married at this time
because there were laws
in the United States
against interracial marriage.
They were finally able to marry
in 1948 when California changed
that law, and they were together
until Howe passed away in 1976.
That's a good shot of Charles
Korvin in the sunglasses
and this great old gas station.
And James Hilton, now
he was a novelist.
He wrote Lost Horizon, Random
Harvest, Goodbye, Mr. Chips,
all made into successful
and popular films.
And this is a typical home movie
gag, oops, we forgot somebody.
Sanora Babb waves Howe
back into the car.
They seem to really
love each other.
Babb had an interesting
life in her own right.
She was a writer.
She wrote a really
good novel called
Whose Names Are Unknown about
her experiences in the Dust
Bowl and working for the
Farm Security Administration,
and I really recommend it.
Now we're in San
Francisco's Chinatown,
and some beautiful
shots of the buildings.
Howe actually was born in China
and he came with his family
to the United States when
he was just a little boy.
Some cute kids.
And now we're back on the
road with a paper map.
Remember those, Randy?
I still have some.
So do I. And a beautiful
shot of Sanora Babb.
And there's Howe in
the side view mirror.
Let's hope he's not driving.
Well, that was really
terrific, Lynne,
and now it's time for
yet another segment.
This time we've
got a special guest
to join us, the son of
a legendary director,
who worked as a behind
the scenes person
in films for many years himself.
He was the son of
Henry Koster who
directed really great classics
like The Bishop's Wife
and Harvey, and Deanna
Durbin musicals and lots
of other great films.
So please welcome Bob Koster.
Bob, thanks for joining us.
Oh, it's my pleasure.
Thank you for having me.
Hi, Bob.
Hi, Lynne.
Bob, your dad was kind of an
interesting guy in that he
was born in Berlin and ended
up making films in Berlin,
but then came over to the
United States in the 1930s.
But he also was a guy who was
not only a consummate filmmaker
but a consummate entertainer.
His films had a very humanist,
light, multi-layered touch.
So let's take a journey with you
and your dad and his home movie
camera.
I would love it if Bob
would tell a little story
about his father leaving
Europe before we roll the film,
because it's a quite
interesting story about how
your father came to leave
Europe as the Nazis were coming
to power.
Well, Dad knew he would
have to leave Europe.
He would have to leave
Germany at any rate,
because Hitler had
just come to power,
and there were laws against
Jewish people earning a living,
actually.
And so he could no
longer direct in Berlin.
He was just
finishing up a movie.
He went to the bank to get
his money out so that he could
pay for the railroad
ticket out of Germany,
and there was a bank teller
there who the day before
had been a friend of his.
Now the fellow was
wearing a Nazi uniform.
He was an SA officer.
And Dad said, I'd like
to take my money out.
He said, what's your name?
It was the guy who had greeted
him as a friend the day before,
and Dad said, well,
it's Henry Koster.
And he said, you don't
have any money here,
and Dad said, yes, I do.
And he took his passbook
out of his pocket
and handed it to the man, and
the man without looking at it
tore it up and threw
it on the floor.
Dad was not happy about
that, and Dad said,
I would like to see the manager.
And this guard said,
Mr. Schmidt is not here.
And Dad said, well,
then I'll wait for him,
and Dad sat down
at the man's desk.
And they waited a few minutes.
And the guard realized
Dad wasn't going to leave,
and he said, hold on a second,
and he picked up the phone.
He dialed a number.
He said, hello, Mr Schmidt.
He said, I have a Jew
here named Koster who
wants to take his money out.
OK, I'll tell him.
And he hung up and he
turned to Dad and he said,
Mr Schmidt is not here.
And Dad said, well,
wait a minute,
you were just talking
to him on the phone.
And the man made a really
bad mistake at that point.
He said, you Jew bastard,
you're calling me a liar.
And Dad lost his
temper and picked up
the telephone in his hand and
knocked the man out with it.
And Mr. Schmidt came and
pulled Dad off of the teller
and hustled him
out the front door
and took some money
out of his own pocket
and handed it to
my father and said,
look, you take this money, and
you go to the railroad station
and leave the country right now.
And Dad said, but
I'm on my lunch hour.
Doesn't matter.
If you don't do that,
you'll be killed.
Dad left Germany
on his lunch hour
with the clothes on his
back, with whatever money
this man had given him.
And he went to France.
He happened to have his
passport in his pocket.
That's how he left Germany.
That was 1933.
He wandered around Europe,
stayed in Paris a little while,
went to Budapest.
Re-met, since he had
known him before,
Joe Pasternak who was working
in Europe for Carl Laemmle,
the owner of Universal.
And Pasternak, who knew my
dad, hired him as a director.
And they did four
movies together.
After he had made
these movies, Laemmle
hired him to come to
Hollywood in 1936.
And the movie that
Dad made, which
was called Three Smart
Girls with Deanna Durbin,
and the movie following it
which was 100 Men and A Girl,
brought Universal
out of bankruptcy.
It's amazing.
And that was his first Hollywood
film - Three Smart Girls.
Three Smart Girls, yeah.
Well, maybe we should have
a look at these home movies
when we can see him
actually coming over
to the United States.
And we'll go from there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Oh, here we are.
Those are people waving
him goodbye in Austria
when he got on the train to
go from Vienna around Germany
because they couldn't
go through Germany.
Here, they --
Pasternak and my dad --
my dad is on the right,
Pasternak on the left --
on the deck of the ship,
discussing what movies
they're going to make.
They were on the Ile De France.
In those days, one of the
really luxurious cruising ships.
Of course, they didn't
have cruises in those days.
They just crossed the ocean.
Oh, look.
There's my mother.
Kitty, Kitty Koster.
I have no idea
who this lady was.
But I certainly wish I did.
She -- she had
the moves, anyway.
Look at that.
That's New York when they
arrived on February 21, 1936.
That's Pasternak.
That's New York.
Those are the docks, those
were people waiting for people
coming on the Ile De France.
And that's my
father's first house
on Bronson Avenue in Hollywood.
Wow, so he made --
That's my father's
first wife, actually.
My mother.
And that gentleman was Mr. Rubin
who was teaching Dad English.
He didn't speak English.
So now, we're jumping
ahead to 1949,
behind the scenes of
Come to the Stable.
This is Elsa Lanchester
who was the wife
of Charles Laughton who was
one of Dad's best friends.
There is Celeste Holm.
And there is Joe
LaShelle, the cameraman.
And he did several
pictures with Dad.
You ever see a nun
smoking before?
I haven't.
Celeste Holm, Loretta Young
were the two major nuns
in the picture.
And there were a number of
others as you could see.
So this is behind the scenes.
This fellow is making snow
because, believe it or not,
in Beverly Hills, California,
there's no snow in the winter.
That was Hugh Marlowe.
This is Thomas Gomez.
And the lady's name --
Marion Martin.
She plays the manicurist.
And here is obviously Loretta
Young who needs a manicure.
Oh, I guess not.
She's doing all right.
Oh, look.
There's my stepmother, Peggy
Moran, with Celeste Holm.
And Celeste is bouncing
a tennis racket.
And there is Loretta
Young with her daughter.
What was her name again?
Judy.
Yeah.
And that is the daughter of
Clark Gable with Loretta Young.
Although, you're not
supposed to know that.
And there's Hugh
Marlowe with his wife.
Yeah, K.T. Stevens.
K.T. Stevens, of course.
Joe LaShelle, trying
to sneak off the set.
He failed.
And his assistant, this
gentleman, was Ray Wise Mala.
He was born in Alaska.
And he was the
first Alaska native
to work as a cameraman
in Hollywood.
He also did quite
a bit of acting
in the 1930s and early 1940s.
And then he decided he was
better off as a cameraman.
So he became a cameraman.
And he was very good at it.
And there is Celeste Holm
bouncing up and down.
And there's Ray, Ray Mala.
He worked with LaShelle
on the film Laura.
And also, he worked on Shadow
of a Doubt, the Hitchcock film.
Well, LaShelle was kind of his
mentor in doing camerawork.
A very nice man.
I remember him.
And his grandson, Ted Mala
is still a very good friend.
He lives in Anchorage.
There is Loretta Young again.
There is my father with
his scarf and dark glasses.
There's some lights
in the background
that you never see those
kind of lights anymore.
Those are arcs.
They use them to fill in.
There's Dad being
proud of himself,
and rightly so, I might say.
And there's Celeste.
How many times have you
seen nuns playing tennis?
And she was good at it, too.
And in a moment you
will see Louis Jean --
Heydt or Heydt?
I think it's Heydt,
but I'm not positive.
Heydt is better than Heydt, OK.
[CHUCKLES]
Anyway--
And that's Dorothy Patrick.
Oh, Dorothy Patrick.
That's right.
Everybody's doing their
nails at this picture.
Look at those cameras.
Now, everybody
carries phones, huh.
Yeah, that was a good picture.
And it was in black and white.
So it's great to see this color
footage behind the scenes.
That was really fantastic.
Thanks so much,
Bob, for joining us.
And thanks for depositing these
films with the Academy Film
Archive and allowing us to
share them with the world.
It's really terrific to have
the films of a director who
not only enjoyed
doing home movies,
but behind the scenes films as
well where we can see that he
had his different family and
a separate family on the set
when he made his films.
That familial feeling
really comes across.
So thanks again.
Well, the Academy, of course,
is where the films belong.
Absolutely.
So that anybody who's
interested can go and see them,
and they become part
of your history.
Thanks so much, Bob.
My pleasure.
So now we're moving on
to our next home movie.
And this one's very short.
So I wanted to tell you
a little bit about it
before we watch it.
This footage was shot by
writer-director Richard Brooks
in November of 1948 at an
exhibition baseball game.
Brooks has captured one
of the all-time baseball
greats, the legendary
Satchel Paige
pitching for a team of
barnstorming Negro League
players.
And several of those players
are members of the famed Kansas
City Monarchs.
Paige was only the
seventh Negro Leaguer
to join a Major League team.
He signed with the Cleveland
Indians in the summer of 1948.
And he helped Cleveland to
win the pennant and the World
Series that year.
Now the Negro Leagues were
formed because the Major
Leagues were segregated.
Negro Leagues were
very important
in the African-American
community.
But there's very little motion
picture footage of them.
The white newsreels
didn't cover them
and Hollywood didn't
make films about them.
So these home movie
images are very rare.
All the more so because
they're in color.
So let's have a look.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Here we go to Wrigley
Field, Los Angeles,
the minor league ballpark
in LA at that time, home
of the Pacific Coast League.
And here comes Satchel
Paige to the mound.
He's wearing his
Cleveland uniform
while his teammates are
wearing their Royals uniforms.
That was the name of
their barnstorming team.
That's Louis B.
Mayer on the left,
and MGM musical producer
Arthur Freed on the right.
Number 30 walking
out to the mound
is Gene Bearden who was a rookie
phenom for Cleveland in 1948.
And his team is called the Bob
Lemon Gene Bearden All Stars.
They're a team of Major Leaguers
playing against the Royals.
So, beautiful shot of
the ballpark by Brooks.
And there's Paige
pitching the ball.
And that might not
seem like a big deal,
but I have never seen
any other footage
of Paige pitching in a game.
I hope there's some out there,
and I hope some day we find it.
But in the meantime, it
goes to show how valuable
a home movie like this is.
I love these women,
very dressed up.
I don't usually dress up
quite so much myself when
I go to the ballpark.
So Paige is pitching the
first game of a double header,
and he wins his game
against Gene Bearden.
And then they move on
to the second game,
and the Royals lose that one.
So they even it out.
There's producer Bill Goetz
with some other spectators
in the background.
The MGM folk may be
here because they
were working on a film right
now called The Stratton
Story with James Stewart,
which is a baseball themed
film about Monty Stratton.
And Gene Bearden was
actually in that film.
He has a part as one of the
teammates of Jimmy Stewart's.
Mayer seems to be
quite enjoying himself.
There's Gene Bearden in the
gray sitting with the MGM folks
and signing an autograph.
And now we get
the Goodyear Blimp
trailing an advertising banner.
And that's the end.
And now, we're heading
up to San Francisco
for the premiere of China Gate.
This is the Fox Theater
on Market Street.
And the film was
directed by Sam Fuller.
It was also written and
produced by Sam Fuller.
And he got 20th Century
Fox to distribute it.
Given that it was not a
big studio production,
the premiere is a
little more kind
of home grown than your
typical Hollywood premiere.
So we have some local
talent to entertain
the premiere attendees here.
Sam Fuller often made his films
outside the typical studio
system.
And that way, he got
to make the films
he wanted to make as opposed to
what he would have been given.
So sadly, Angie Dickinson
wasn't able to make it
to the premiere.
But both Gene Barry
and Nat King Cole
show up in a couple of minutes.
Nat King Cole had made a
number of films prior to this.
But he always played the part
of a singer or played himself.
And in this film,
he actually got
to play an actual acting role.
He played a soldier.
And he was probably
drawn to the part
because the film had
an anti-racist theme.
Cole, of course, was already
a hugely popular singer
at this time.
In the course of his career,
he had 100 different songs
or more really that
were on the pop charts.
He also, at this time, was
making a television series
called The Nat King Cole Show.
So here come our
celebrity guests.
That's Sam Fuller in
front of the limo.
That's Maria Cole who just
got out with a white wrap.
Gene Barry getting out
now with his wife, Betty.
And here's Nat King Cole...
Posing for some publicity shots.
Maria Cole was also a singer.
And of course, her
daughter with Nat King Cole
is Natalie Cole, another
very famous singer.
Gene Barry may be
best known for playing
Bat Masterson in that TV
series and had many other film
and television credits.
He's also in the Fuller
film, Forty Guns.
And some of the other
actors from that film
come to the premiere as
well to support Fuller.
So Cole goes over to talk
to some of the little girls.
And I think he's just
very sweet about this.
You can tell he's
asking her name,
and he doesn't quite hear
it and he asked her again.
And Gene Barry lifts
one of them up.
I hope she's enjoying that as
much as it looks like she is.
Nat King Cole takes a
turn with the baton.
He's very talented.
Why not?
And now we've added George
Givot on the far left.
He's also in this film.
And he started out in the early
days in the Ziegfeld Follies.
Probably best known for
being the voice of Luigi
in The Lady and the Tramp.
That's Barry Sullivan
who's in Forty Guns,
and also Eve Brent in
the stoll, and Robert Dix
next to her, both in
Forty Guns as well.
And we don't know
who this lady is,
but she sure looks like
she belongs at a Hollywood
premiere, doesn't she?
So in they go to see the
premiere of China Gate.
It's so good to see
this footage of Nat King
Cole, wonderful talent.
And I'm equally excited for
our next home movie clip
because it features one of
my absolute favorite stars.
It's footage from the set of
The Trouble With Angels shot
by Gypsy Rose Lee and --
who is also in the film.
But we're going to be joined
today by our star of the film.
Please welcome one of my
very favorite actresses
for my whole life, Hayley Mills.
Thank you, Randy.
It's lovely to
join you for this.
I'm looking forward to it.
Me, too.
And I realize this
was a long time ago.
You were just a kid.
And at the same
time, hopefully, this
will bring back some memories.
Yes, I hope -- well,
it is a long time ago.
I was 19.
But to have this
footage jogs the memory.
I just wanted to ask you a
few questions about Trouble
With Angels and
the film before we
start looking at this footage.
So you grew up in a family where
this was the family business.
You were in acting.
You had your father who
was a well-known actor,
your mother was an
actor but also a writer.
And of course, your
sister, as well.
How did you guys
juggle your schedules?
Well, it was quite a headache
for my mother because hitherto,
she had always gone
wherever my dad was working.
And then I started working.
So then she was split
between being with him
and being with me.
But then Disney arranged
for me to have a guardian.
So that released my mother.
She didn't have
to sit on the set.
She wasn't really cut out
to be a stage mom at all.
So that was much better.
I was 19.
And I really didn't need
to have my mom anymore.
So I -- it was the first
time that I went to Hollywood
on my own.
The production gave me the
most incredible trailer.
It was literally the
length of a city block.
It was huge and empty.
It had an enormous
kitchen and everything.
I remember I used to buy those
ready-made packets of dough
which you chopped up into little
bits and put them in the oven
and they turned into biscuits.
And I would take
them on to the set.
That's about the only
cooking I ever did.
So I was there on
my own by that time,
which was quite an experience.
That's really terrific to think
of you passing out biscuits.
Your sister was
working on Broadway
when you were starting
out and received a Tony
nomination for her performance.
Shortly after that time, you
received a Juvenile Oscar
for your performance
in Pollyanna.
So your parents suddenly
had these two award winning
actresses in their family.
What was that like?
Well, it was very exciting.
When I got mine, I was 14.
I think it took a few years
for it to really sink in.
I don't think I really fully
appreciated the relevance
until I was older.
And of course, I didn't
go to the ceremony.
I think if I had
gone to the ceremony,
it would have had
more of an impact.
When I was at school,
in my boarding school,
I think my parents decided
that it would probably
have gone straight to my head
and turned me into a brat.
So --
Let's watch this footage.
And you can tell us some
of your experiences.
And I'll have a
few more questions
that we can talk a
little bit after.
Yes.
This is footage from the
Gypsy Rose Lee Collection
featuring you, Hayley, Rosalind
Russell, and director Ida
Lupino.
Smile quietly.
[CHUCKLES]
So Mother Superior
was the working title.
And here we go with
actress Rosalind Russell.
Roz -- she was great.
She was a very
impressive person.
Beautiful and impressive.
And Binnie Barnes, yeah.
Marvelous.
There's Ida Lupino
directing away.
Oh.
Ida -- Yes.
Probably very good
I didn't decide
to become a percussionist.
I don't think I had a
great talent for it.
There's your co-star,
June Harding.
[CHUCKLES]
June -- she was so good.
Such a sweet girl.
This is at the Greystone
Mansion in Los Angeles.
Oh, gosh.
Yes.
All that fake snow.
If you sneezed, it went
straight up your nose.
[GASPS]
Oh, and there's Mary Wickes.
She's so wonderful.
I loved her.
The Mother Superior
having a crafty cigarette.
I love June's bouffant
underneath that hoodie.
Yes.
[CHUCKLES]
They had to keep putting this
white powder onto our backsides
because we're supposed
to have fallen down.
But of course,
the more you walk,
the more the powder fell off
which was quite funny, really,
particularly since it was
probably about 90 degrees heat.
And the whole crew were
sweltering and wearing
Hawaiian shirts.
And we're having fake
snow put all over us.
That's show business, I guess.
Oh, here we are.
Yes, Gypsy Rose Lee.
I was thrilled to
meet her, actually.
It was extraordinary.
I never thought I would
meet Gypsy because I'd
seen her film by this time.
And here she was, standing
in front of me in the flesh.
She was glamorous, and very
sweet, and funny, and very,
very down to earth.
I think that was part
of her great appeal
and why she was
so very successful
as a striptease artist is that
she seemed to sort of keep it
at a distance.
But I mean, she never
looked down on her audience.
But she didn't seem to take
it 100% seriously either.
She always had a sense
of humor about it.
The footage here where you're
dancing with the scarves
is not in the film.
So this is some outtakes
we're able to see here.
Because what I really
wanted Gypsy to do
was teach me her
burlesque routine.
Yeah, you had two --
well, three really remarkable
women on this film with
Rosalind Russell,
Gypsy Rose Lee --
who had achieved so
much in her life.
She was a very
successful businesswoman.
She was a very good writer.
And Ida Lupino.
I think she was one of the only,
if not the only, female film
director at that time in
Hollywood, which is really
saying something in an industry
largely dominated by men.
And Ida seems to be
directing everybody
here very specifically on
what she wants people to do.
She was very decisive, very
sure, very absolutely clear
about what she wanted.
There was no sort
of faffing around.
Ida -- she always
looked wonderful.
Bill Frye, our
producer, suggested
that she wore only black
and white on the set.
Sometimes, she wore hats.
Ah, I wish I knew what she said.
Obviously made everybody laugh.
Oh, yes.
And Ida used to insist that
we all call her Mother.
And on the back of her chair
was written Mother Of Us All.
Yes, three remarkable
women, strong women,
clever, talented women.
And here comes another mother.
And of course, everybody
in their nun's habit
just suits everybody.
And it focused you on
the essential things
about a person, their face,
their eyes, their smile.
There's something
wonderful about that.
June's birthday.
I think that candle was --
they probably stole
that off the altar.
I don't know how old she was.
I think she was --
she was certainly older than me.
Yeah.
I think she was about 28, about
almost 10 years older than you.
She didn't seem like it.
She had a youthful energy.
Yes, she did.
I wish I could lip read and
know what we were talking about.
[LAUGHS]
She was great.
She had such gaiety.
Gypsy's holding a
small microphone there.
She'd bring along her
small portable tape
recorder and microphone
because not only would she
shoot home movies, she
would record sound.
She'd take that wild
sound and add it
to the home movies later
along with little interviews.
And sometimes, she'd edit
them together and show them
on her very popular television
show, The Gypsy Rose Lee Show
Oh.
A bit challenging
after all that cake.
[CHUCKLES]
Oh, it's lovely to see this.
Lovely.
That was really fun to hear
you talk about it, too.
And especially about the
strong women on the set.
Could you talk a little bit
about Ida Lupino's directing
style?
Having been an actress,
she let everybody
do what they wanted to do.
She saw what they had
brought to the set
and then make suggestions.
Some film directors,
surprisingly, leave it up
to the actors and they're
interested more in
where they're going
to put the camera
or how they're going to cut the
scene, their overall vision.
So they leave what the actors
are doing up to the actors.
And then you've
got directors who
give so much attention
to actors and leave
all of the technical things
to their cameraman and editor.
And Ida had a very
good idea of both.
She certainly made me feel
confident, and I trusted her.
It seemed odd to have
a woman as a director
because in my experience,
it had always been a man.
Now, suddenly, it's a woman.
And it was a little odd.
And then I began to enjoy it.
I really appreciated it.
I really liked her.
And that sort of changed
my perspective, I suppose,
about what was the woman's
role, what was the man's role.
And then here is this very
successful woman director
who didn't have to
deny her femininity.
She didn't try to be manly.
She wasn't -- she didn't
wear suits and march about,
which sounds like a
silly thing to say,
but she was just herself.
And I think that's
why looking back,
it's rather sweet and
rather clever of her
to say that everybody
had to call her Mother.
Everybody else except
the cast on the set
were men, except the makeup
and the hair and the wardrobe
department.
So if you're calling
the director Mother,
you're going to be a
little bit more respectful.
[CHUCKLES]
They've all got mothers.
But I think it was quite clever.
I'm Mother of you all.
You know, I'm not
challenging you,
I'm not competing with you.
So one of the interesting
things about Ida Lupino
is when she was an
actress in the early '30s,
she already had a career
going in Hollywood.
But she had contracted polio,
and her contract with Paramount
was dropped because
of her illness.
During that time when
she thought maybe
her acting career
might be over, she
realized that while
intellectually she was fine,
she could still
write, it was then
that she began thinking
about directing.
Really, that kind of difficulty
made her re-evaluate and then
ended up creating the
pathway for the only director
in the Directors Guild who
was a woman in the '50s was
Ida Lupino.
I think it's really
terrific that there
is an even more poignant part
to the story above and beyond
fighting for a position.
That's very interesting.
I didn't know that.
And of course, it
was at a time when
women were beginning to really
challenge the status quo.
So she was definitely one of the
first, as was Gypsy Rose Lee.
I think one of the interesting
things about this film
is that it was so
female-centric in a time
when that wasn't
really very common.
And yet at the same
time, there were examples
and there were people
pushing the boundaries.
So --
Yeah.
My big disappointment
with the film --
when I first read the
script, I remember
being absolutely thrilled
that I was finally going
to get into a nun's habit.
Because like so many --
I'm sure like so
many girls, there's
something terribly romantic
about being a bride of Christ
and a life of contemplation
and public service,
and apart from anything, wearing
all those wonderful things.
And I did think about becoming
a nun, actually, for a while.
Then when we got to
the film, and they
decided they wouldn't
go to the point
where she actually
dons the habit,
I was terribly disappointed.
But anyway, there we are.
You can't have everything.
[CHUCKLING]
And you're writing
your memoir, I hear.
So that's really fantastic.
I look forward to that.
Yes, I am.
I am.
So you've stirred up
the old phagocytes,
so thank you very much.
A pleasure.
For our last segment, we've
got a very special treat.
One of the other things
that the Academy has
is an Oral History Program.
We've been shooting
interviews with a lot
of people from all various
branches of the Academy.
It's really fantastic to
have their memories recorded.
We realized that we had a
very special oral history, one
with Gregory Nava where Greg
not only talked about growing up
in San Diego, but also narrated
some of the home movies
and watched them with our
moderator at that time.
So we're going to show these
with the very special sound
of a projector in the
background, which I
think is very nostalgic for me.
If you have a home
movie projector,
you'll probably recognize
what's going on.
And at the same time, you'll
hear his live reaction
to these films and
the people in them.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When I grew up, my
parents were always
taking home movies, 8
millimeter home movies.
My whole life is on 8
So let's take a look at
some of these images,
and some of the people who
we'll be talking about.
This is me.
I think it's my third birthday.
Happy Birthday, Greg.
And that's my older
brother, John.
And he, of course, has become
a very, very famous painter.
He did all of the tapestries
on the inside of the cathedral
in downtown Los Angeles.
And there I am on the
right, the younger brother.
And that's our little
house in San Diego.
We were very poor.
And we lived in a
little clapboard house
behind another house, right?
[CHUCKLES]
There's my mom.
We didn't have a lot of
money, but she always
made sure that we were always
clean, very well dressed.
She was always
very well dressed.
There, you have a really
nice look at our little house
that I was raised in as a child.
And there's my
grandmother, Sebastiana.
She was Basque
from the Pyrenees.
And we were very, very close --
the family, all of us were.
And she was a great, great lady.
And there's my
grandfather in the middle.
Aita, we called him, which
means father in Basque.
And you see the man
in the Hawaiian shirt
is named Paul Nelson.
That's my father
with Paul Nelson.
And they were buddies
in World War II.
There's so many Latinos
fought in the war,
but their story was never told.
The first time a Latino
GI story was ever told
was on my TV show
American Family,
and that's the reason I did it.
And this is my brother and I.
And we're going down to Mexico
to my grandfather's ranch.
That's my uncle
John with my dad.
And this is my uncle Martin
who is the great villain
of the family, who was
characterized in the film
A Time of Destiny
played by William Hurt.
And there we are going
down to the ranch
with the beautiful matilija
poppies that would grow wild.
This is us at the
Descanso Ranch having
a barbecue with my family.
You see my cousin Pammy
there with that red hair.
That's very Basque.
And Melissa Leo, that's
one of the reasons
I picked her for the role of
Josie in A Time of Destiny
because she had that brilliant
strawberry blonde hair.
That's my Aunt Jessie
on the right there.
And there's always a
character in all of my films
that's based on my Aunt Jessie.
That's Toyah.
She was married
to my uncle John.
She's indigena, from Colima.
And you see all this mixture of
peoples that were at the ranch.
And I based a lot of
characters on Toyah.
She was a very strong
woman, very resilient.
If you asked my
father what he was,
what was his most important
thing, he would say,
I'm a father.
He was raised without a
father, because in the late
'20s and early '30s, there was
this tremendous thing that is
very little dealt with -- and
I deal with it in the film Mi
Familia, and this is why I dealt
with it in the film Mi Familia
-- where they had
the deportations,
where they blamed the Depression
on Mexican people who were
taking away jobs
from real Americans.
My Mexican grandfather
was an American citizen.
They took his citizenship
away, his papers at the border,
and he was sent back to Mexico.
He disappeared.
And my father was
raised without a father.
And so that, to him, he want --
that was more important to him
that he wanted to be a
really wonderful father.
And that's another
reason why, in my films,
there's very positive
father figures.
There's my dad.
Look at him.
Such a handsome
beautiful man, huh?
Look at them.
There's my grandmother.
She never liked to
have her picture taken.
And there's my Aunt
Lucy, and she's pregnant.
You see how my Aita's
playing the saxophone,
being a real clown.
And there's my Uncle
Vale from Tijuana.
And he's playing the trumpet.
And he owned the car
dealership in Tijuana.
He was very wealthy.
And my cousins Valito and Josie.
And my Aunt Lucy, and she was
so beautiful, my Aunt Lucy.
She reminded me of
like Evita because she
would come to our house
in furs and in diamonds.
In our family, the Mexican
family was the wealthy family,
and we were poor.
You can see that these --
the women of my family are very
powerful and very assertive,
aren't they?
Incredible.
And it's so sad.
One of the great
tragedies of my family.
You see my Aunt Lucy there.
She's pregnant.
She died two weeks after
this movie was taken.
And looking at these movies,
when I saw that film that you
just saw, and I
saw my Aunt Lucy --
and I hadn't seen her and
thought of her for so many
years --
all of these things
came back to me.
And I realized how much the
things that happened to me with
my childhood, the contrast
between these worlds of Mexico
and the United States, the
personal tragedies around
people like my Aunt Lucy,
like my grandfather,
the war experiences
of my father,
my uncle Martin who was such
a bad guy, all these faces,
and the names --
Irene, Tony, they're all
the names of my aunts
and my cousins --
and I saw all these faces
looking at me from this movie.
And I was seeing all the
characters of my films.
Wow, that is just so wonderful.
Such wonderful stories
and wonderful home movies.
Thank you, Gregory Nava.
To think that little boy that
we see with his birthday cake
at the beginning growing up
to be the director of El Norte
and Selena and Mi Familia
is really terrific.
So, really happy we have that.
So we promised you
not only to show
you some really rare and
unusual Hollywood Home Movies,
but we also promised
to tell you about how
to save and preserve and
share your own home movies.
So here is one of
the Academy Film
Archive's archivists,
Sean Savage,
to tell you a little bit about
how to deal with your home
movie collection.
I'm Sean.
I'm an archivist at the
Academy Film Archive.
And I've been working with
home movies at home lately.
But that's my job.
You may have home movies
that are your own.
Of course, if you have
a working projector
and you want to run
them from time to time,
that's great since
that's why they
were made in the first place.
But more likely, you've probably
encountered family films
from a previous
generation, and you may not
know what to do with them.
They might be in cans or boxes
or could be different gages,
16 or 8 millimeter, Super 8
-- the main thing is that film
likes to be cool and dry.
So if you've got a closet
where the temperature doesn't
fluctuate much,
that's probably fine.
But a hot attic or the
garage or a dank basement
would not be good.
And film likes to breathe.
So keep them individually
in containers
that aren't totally airtight.
These are fancy archival
cans that we use.
And these were designed
to circulate air.
But you know, the original box
or can should be fine as long
as it's not totally
sealed, which
means we probably want to
take them out of plastic bags
if you find them like this.
And sometimes, you'll
find rubber bands
wrapped around the film.
And that's not good
because that's just
going to dry out and
leave a mess over time.
So the best thing to do is
find some artist tape and just
tape the ends down that way.
A lot of people had their
home movies transferred to VHS
in the 1980s.
And if you look at
them now, they probably
don't look so great.
The speed could be wrong
or the image might even
be flipped horizontally.
You may have had
better luck with DVDs
in the 1990s or 2000s.
But in any case, never
throw your home movies away.
There's always going to
be a better technology
to get the most
from the film image.
And your original
reels are probably
going remain more stable
than any format you
transfer them to.
If you have no use for
film reels at the house,
you can donate
them to an archive.
This is not a pitch,
but at the Academy,
we collect all kinds
of amateur films,
not just those of movie stars.
We're particularly interested
in things that document life
in Southern California.
But wherever you live,
there's a good chance
that there's a regional archive
or historical society that
may be interested in them.
I think the best way to
re-engage with home movies is
Home Movie Day.
And these are events that
happen all over the world
usually in October.
And they invite you to bring
your reels in and watch them
with other people
in your community.
You'll find moving
image archivists on hand
to help guide you.
I recommend going to
homemovieday.com to find out
what's happening near you.
And this is also the site for
the Center for Home Movies.
And there, you'll find
resources on everything
you need to know about
what to do with your reels.
Well, thank you, Sean.
That was terrific.
And I hope everybody out
there with home movies
got a few good ideas about
how to take care of them,
and to remember to always
keep your original films.
Now, we'd like to wrap
things up by thanking
all of our collaborators
and contributors
and special guests.
Randy?
Yes.
Well, I also want
to say thank you
to Sean Savage for bringing the
special guest of the hula dog
because you can't have
a Hollywood Home Movie
show without some
trained canines involved
as far as I'm concerned.
Anyway, thank you, Lynne,
for curating this whole show.
I'd like to thank
Michael Mortilla
for bringing the musical
accompaniment to bring them
to life.
I'd like to thank Bob
Koster and Sean Savage
for presenting special
segments, as well as Gregory
Nava, the director, showing
his family's movies,
and of course, our special
guest star, Hayley Mills.
Thank you very much,
Hayley, for joining us.
And, Lynne, I hope
you're already
thinking about what Part
Two is going to be like.
Thanks so much.
Thank you.
Bye, Everybody.
Bye!
[MUSIC PLAYING]